president Trump's former national
security adviser Michael Flynn is
working on a deal to answer questions
from the FBI and House and Senate
intelligence committees Flynn won't say
promise of legal protection before
testifying about the Trump campaign and
Russian meddling in the election
Michael Flint's lawyer said in a
statement last night general Flynn
certainly has the story to tell and he
very much wants to tell it the attorney
says there must be in his words
assurances against unfair prosecution
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
where two officials are now at the
center of another controversy Margaret
good morning good morning well the White
House is playing defense again as news
surfaced that Michael Flynn is seeking
that legal protection before answering
questions about Russia contacts that as
news broke showing that White House
staffers selectively leaked information
in order to justify the president's
claims that he was unfairly surveilled
mr. chairman are you willing to say
anything about these in this I'm not
gonna say anything just because it's
another appropriate place to do it
arriving back in his California district
last night House Intelligence chair
Devin newness refused to comment on news
that former Trump national security
adviser Michael Flynn requested immunity
from FBI prosecution that in exchange
for testimony about potential Russian
contacts with the Trump campaign during
the election Flynn criticized aides to
Hillary Clinton for seeking legal
immunity during the probe into her
private email server when you get given
immunity that means that you've probably
committed a crime Nunez who'd previously
served as a trump transition official is
leading the house investigation into
those Russian contacts I never said I
would provide you answers I said we
would look into it White House spokesman
Sean Spicer deflected questions about
whether the administration is trying to
influence that inquiry by leaking
selective information even after noonas
admitted he was given key evidence while
at the White House I cannot get into who
those individuals were the New York
Times identified the congressman sources
as NSC staffer Ezra Cohen watt Nick a
friend of trumps son-in-law Jared
Kushner and Michael Ellis a White House
lawyer who previously worked for Nunez
their bosses and as
the legal adviser John Eisenberg and
White House Council Don McGann were
likely also aware noonas refusal to
share information with fellow
investigators has raised eyebrows yet
House Speaker Paul Ryan told CBS this
morning that he had full confidence in
it he had told me that like a
whistleblower type person had given him
some information that was new our goal
is to be as forthright as possible the
White House invited Senate and House
Intelligence Committee leaders to
privately view the documents relevant to
the investigations but congressman Adam
Schiff said their secrecy was perplexing
they can present it to the White House
staff or the President himself at any
time so why all the cloak-and-dagger
stuff charlie both the White House and
Michael Flynn's lawyers say that all of
this is just a political witch-hunt
Thank You Margaret